let's get more with the shadow attorney
general Labor's Emily Thornbury do you
stand by the ads as well miss Thornbury
good morning happy Easter good morning
happy Easter k
um of course we do of course we do why
would we not listen the criminal justice
system in this country has completely
collapsed and it's happened over the 13
years that the conservatives have been
in power and Rishi sunak is in charge of
the government and should do something
about it and isn't
because I suppose one of the reasons
that people are being so squeamish about
it and you know there's been quite the
backlash on Twitter and other social
media is the suggestion that the Prime
Minister doesn't want to put sex
offenders in jail and he takes very much
exception to that well let's put it this
way if it's such a priority for him then
why doesn't he do something about it
which means why doesn't he make sure
that the Attorney General puts proper
there's something called an unduly
leaning sentences regime where if
something if someone has been given a
sentence which people feel is too low
then it can be referred to the attorney
general and then she makes a decision
about sending it to the court of appeal
so the court of appeal can have another
look at it and frankly under Sue Ella
bravaman for the two years that she was
attorney general hardly anyone was sent
who was a child sex abuser or
um or a child pornographer was sent to
was sent to the account to the court of
appeal to be to have their sentence
looked at again it is disgraceful on top
of that the Lord chief justice had to
advise judges that given how overcrowded
our prisons are that the judges should
think should think again before sending
someone to prison and we've heard we've
heard from barristers saying that people
are less likely to be sent to prison
because of the amount of time that it
takes between the original offense and
someone coming before the courts I mean
if you are an alleged rapist you have a
two percent chance of actually being
charged if a a someone complains about
you
um a two percent chance of coming to
court and then it's a three-year wait
for the case to come to court I mean
this simply isn't right and as Kia says
in his article today you know what does
that say to the brave women who come
forward to make these complaints it says
that we're not taking this matter
seriously I can tell you labor is but
this government is not taking this
matter seriously and doesn't really care
if they cared they would do something
about it
one of the reasons for the backlog as we
know of course is because of the
pandemic and the problems of getting
people into court during that too you're
right k a period yeah that's certainly
one of the reasons but it isn't the only
reason and the backlog was already
really bad before and they had closed
courts in order to save money and they
weren't uh recruiting judges in order to
save money you know that and they didn't
have enough prosecutors and they weren't
paying people to do criminal defense
work and so people were moving on to do
other things instead there was a lack of
barristers there was a lack of Courts
there was a lack of Judges they had
privatized the probation service then
they had deep privatized it they had
messed it around and it's now on its
knees I mean these are things that have
happened under their watch
but
um is it necessary to lower the party's
um esteem to the extent of view from the
public to the extent where you're
suggesting that the prime minister is um
supporting sex offenders I mean what is
that going to say when it comes to the
next election and the campaigns there I
mean I thought it was the conservatives
who were known as the nasty party so two
weeks ago okay that you'll remember the
Prime Minister got up at Prime
Minister's questions and bragged about
the criminal justice system I bragged
about having crime you know which is
Highly Questionable but in any event you
know he was bragging about that and he
was taking the record since 2010 and
saying you know look at us aren't we
great look at me aren't I great well
actually if you want to be accountable
then let's make you accountable let's
make you properly accountable and
actually let's make sure that there's a
debate and one thing can be said over
the last few days at least we're
starting to debate the criminal justice
system which for far too long I think
you know we have been avoiding looking
at but we need to look at hard and you
know as Kiera said you know he's
dedicated his life to ensuring that the
criminal justice system works and he's
going to make sure that if if he is
given the honor of becoming prime
minister this will be be one of his
absolute top priorities is to sort out
criminal justice in this country one of
the things that my viewers will be
United with you about this morning is
those International scam calls that are
catching so many people out thank you so
there are tens of millions of these
calls that are made every year and and
the and for thousands of people it is is
very scary because what happens quite
often is that they target people who are
in their homes in the afternoons
um pensioners quite often and try to
engage them in conversation and the
longer they engage them in conversation
the more likely they are to be able to
to steal their money from them and in
order to be able to to get people to
answer the phone they they instead of it
sort of and most of these calls are made
from overseas and what happens is that
they they cover that up by being and
this is legal they are able to use
British numbers and we simply say this
has to stop and of course must stop it
and they need to go down hard on it and
simply we should not be allowing these
spoof calls is what they're called to be
able to use British numbers because the
reason they're using British numbers is
in order to ensure that people answer
the phone so we need to stop that and
then when it comes to people ringing
from their mobile phone from abroad then
so long as they are registered as a UK
user then that their calls can still
come into the UK but no one else should
be allowed to now we've heard from some
companies that you know that it may be
that they would want to continue to use
their call centers that are based over
broad abroad and would want to be able
to use a British number to which we say
well you know isn't it wouldn't it be
better if you thought about employing
some people in Britain but if you insist
on employing people abroad then we
should have a register and only people
who you are on that register should be
allowed to use a UK number when ringing
from abroad
um just before I let you go um doctors
uh junior doctors about to start um a
four day strike causing absolute Havoc
to the National Health Service we had a
specialist on earlier saying basically
just don't get sick for the next four
days
um the union wants a 35 pay rise your
words treating uh Labor's um Shadow
Health secretary saying he wouldn't give
that the green light is that Labor's
position generally our position
generally is that you should sit down
and talk to people and the government's
position generally is not to do it and
to leave it until the last minute until
we have I think it's is it 130 000
operations and procedures have been
canceled so far
um and it's got worse it's getting worse
and they leave it until the last minute
they wait until people's attitudes have
hardened it becomes harder for them to
be able to come to a deal and then
eventually they come to a deal but only
after in the end the public has suffered
you know we believe that you should sit
down and talk to unions but at the
moment you know Barclays attitude which
is that he's not going to talk to the
junior doctors is ridic ridiculous and
should be condemned we appreciate you
taking the time on a bank holiday Monday
to join us thanks very much as always
I'm sorry thank you